Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, we're getting back
into one of those phases, very much reminiscent
of 20/20, where things are changing relatively
quickly when it comes to the pandemic and the
trajectory over the next two, three, four or five
months. And part of the question that has been
increasingly asked is, will there be a third
vaccine dose? Will there be a recommendation
for some or maybe even most people to get a third
dose of the coronavirus vaccine in order to have
stronger protection against the Delta variant and
or future variants? And over the last 24 hours,
the answer seems to increasingly be pointing to,
yes, let's review a couple of articles about this
CNN article. Pfizer data suggests
third dose of covid-19 vaccine
strongly boosts protection against Delta variant.
Now, there are some important details here. Let's
review a third dose of the Pfizer Bion.
Tek covid-19 vaccine can strongly boost
protection against the Delta variant beyond
the protection afforded by the standard two
doses. New data released by Pfizer on Wednesday
suggests the data posted online suggests that
levels of antibodies that can target the Delta
variant grow five fold in people aged 18 to 55
who get a third dose of the vaccine among people
ages 65 to 85. The Pfizer data suggest antibody
levels that should protect against Delta grow
11 four fold more than following a second dose.
Now, it's not likely that in older folks they get
to a higher level of antibodies. It's that because
in older folks it's looking like the antibodies
start to diminish. It is getting them up at a
greater multiple because they are starting with a
lower base rate. It's just a simple mechanism of
of understanding the base rate. Understand that
this is this is the Keyline. The data involved
tests of 23 people and have not yet been peer
reviewed or published. It is very, very early
in this. But there are other countries studying
this as well, which we will get to in a moment.
So if you were wondering, why does your CDC
vaccination card have more than two slots,
even though up until now the protocol has been two
doses, this may well be why it's another important
detail. It's not clear if boosted antibody levels
actually correlate to better protection or if that
extra protection is even needed. The U.S., CDC
and the U.S. CDC says the current vaccines protect
people well against all the common variants. So
there's a bunch of different factors here. One is.
Does Pfizer have a financial interest in everybody
getting a third? Sure, you could say that,
that there's no question about that. They stand
to make a lot of money. If all of a sudden,
instead of two doses for every American, it's
three doses for every American and people in other
countries as well. The other question is, even
with diminished antibodies, do you have enough
antibodies that you would still, in most cases, be
immune or at least unlikely to get seriously ill?
Because that's the point of a vaccine. If we say
if cases mean mostly colds and vaccinated people,
cases become less important. It's sort
of like well as the cases of the flu,
cases of colds, et cetera. We've talked about
that before. We don't need to go over it again.
Needless to say, other countries are also
investigating this third dose idea and
Israel is going to be moving forward on it. As
you can see here, the Israeli health ministry
recommends a third covid shot for older Israelis.
Most experts on the committee argue for a covid
booster shot for Israelis 60 and above. As the
Delta variant spreads. Experts advising the
health ministry have recommended that older people
receive a third dose of the coronavirus vaccine,
though they disagree on whether the cohort
should start at 60 years old, 65 or 70. Some
of the data presented at a discussion Wednesday
suggested that the vaccine's effectiveness in
preventing severe symptoms among 60 year olds
and above has dropped to eighty one percent from
97 percent in January. While most panel members
favored a booster shot for anyone 60 or older,
others suggested that the bar be raised to 65
or 70. The Health Ministry's director general
will make the final decision. We are seeing a
dramatic drop in the level of immunity, and we
know the elderly respond less to vaccines than the
young. But we don't have this data for covid-19.
Tuesday, the prime minister declared Israel was
very close to making a decision on covid booster
shots and on obtaining additional doses needed.
So for me, there is every indication here that
we're going in the direction of a third
dose, at least for some portion of the US
population, even though there is still some lack
of clarity about even if your antibodies diminish,
you may still have enough antibodies to mostly
protect you from the disease. And again,
this is one of those situations where other
countries are saying third doses, guys were
desperate for some vaccine. Send us anything,
we'll take anything. We'll even give us first
doses for some people. And in the US, we have this
incredibly an extraordinarily privileged situation
where anybody can just walk in and get a first
dose and a second dose if there's a decision made,
about third doses that that we go in the direction
of, yes, those are going to be widely available.
And yet tons of people in the United States still
don't even want to go and get vaccinated. We
are also, fortunately, and it's only a slight
improvement, but fortunately, we are starting
to see vaccination numbers go up in the United
States. Over the last couple of days. We had
a couple of consecutive days where there were
about three hundred and seventy five thousand new
vaccinations, meaning not when it's a two dose
regimen. If you just look at the number of doses,
you don't know how many people that represents
about three hundred and seventy five thousand new
people per day going and getting a vaccine.
Now, you look at that and you say, oh,
my goodness, that's zero point one percent
of the population. That's an improvement.
And it's very depressing when we could be
vaccinating tens of millions of more people.
But the fact that the numbers are going in the
right direction rather than the wrong direction
is certainly something that we can be glad
about. So that's the latest on third doses.
What I want to talk about next is increasingly
understand the framing here. Businesses
making decisions that they judge are good business
decisions for them. OK, let's get into that next.